aujourd'hui mon objectif c'est pouvoir
évoluer pouvoir devenir un exemple
pour moi des stagiaires de formation
liées à la formation des apprentis dans
les quartiers ya beaucoup de talent il
ya beaucoup de potentiel si maintenant
on leur donne leur chance et qu'on les
accompagne correctement forcément y'a
pas de raison que ça se passe pas une
réunion pour l'emploi au ski tubes à
guyancourt les entreprises étaient
présentes ce lundi 18 octobre pour
échanger autour de la thématique
recruter autrement les enjeux pour nous
c'est à la fois permettre aux
entreprises de retrouver la dynamique
qui était la leur avant que vite comme
je vous le disais aussi peut-être
d'orienter des stratégies de manière un
peu différente en tenant compte des
difficultés qu'on a pu rencontrer dans
les périodes de confinement par exemple
recruter autrement mais aussi postuler
autrement à quelques centaines de mètres
de là lagence option un terrible fait
réaliser des cv vidéo à ses chercheurs
d'emploi elle a créé pour cela le site
au petit c'est bon pour un candidat ça
lui apporte 30 % plus de trouver un cdi
par rapport à un cv papier c'est plus
une vitrine en fait vraiment ça va être
la présentation de candidats sont une
vitrine sur son expérience
professionnelle ou non choisie que deux
ou trois on ne veut pas tout expliqué
dans mon cv de vidéo de 2 minutes et
puis bah c'est surtout voilà les
motivations et les atouts du candidat tu
le cv vidéo à la fois nattes ou modernes
pour un candidat et un gain de temps
pour les entreprises dans leur quête de
recrutement
la tendance allait elle est très
favorable à l'emploi puisque on a une
demande de recrutement qui est qui est
bien plus élevé qu'avant la crise au co
vide aujourd'hui il faut mettre en
adéquation justement ses besoins en
recrutement avec la demande d'emploi sur
saint quentin en yvelines et c'est tout
l'enjeu de ces quatre jours qui sont
dédiés à l'emploi et qui démarre
aujourd'hui de nombreux autres rendez
vous dédié à l'emploi sont organisés du
18 au 21 octobre dans le cadre du ski
emploi fait sa rentrée